hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Vita World Cup 2019
while things are heating up in the in
the game for the finals we also need to
check up on the match you young a versus
maxime beaugeois grab
two of them the two of the class pro
games ended in a draw then two of the
rapid games ended in a draw and this is
there a fourth rapid game the one with
the shorter time format
Maxime won Game three of the rapid
section and now young he has the white
pieces and he needs needs a win in order
to equalize and go take this further
into the tiebreaks so without further
ado let's check it out and see who
claims the the third-place young he
opens the width d4 with Knight to f6 c4
g6 and the Knight to c3 and of course
the five add the groom for defenses on
the board Maxime yet again goes for his
famous weapon C captures Knight captures
and just efore going into the main line
tonight captures beak actress Bishop to
g7 with Quinta a four check black needs
to deal with this somehow and we have
Knight to d7 and now Knight to f3
continuing development black does the
same Maxim castles here and now Bishop
to g5 and c5 the usual idea when playing
the groom fold you want to attack white
center with the C pawn with the bishop
and and the fourth Y to deal with this
we've looked d1 getting the work out of
this nasty diagonal also putting putting
it on this very nice file
we've seek after Sun B for C capture Sun
d4 and mountain right back to f6 and
here there is a game where this position
was reached it was in the 2016 Women's
Olympiad
Elizabeth Pyatt said this position
against Maria Karolina Lujan and the
death game ended in a draw now but in
the game Bishop the d3 was played here
we have d5 and it is a new move in the
position but as you know young he really
loves pushing pawns so he's preparing e5
with Bishop to d7 attacking use Queen
here on a4 and now Queen to b4 going
after the b7 pawn and now Queen to b6
working out for Mac seemed as if
captures captures then he gets the very
nice open file for his rook and on the
other hand
the Queen trade is avoided then white
could be in some trouble as this king is
still on a1 and the bishop still hasn't
developed so you hear trial decides to
trade with captures a captures in the
now v5 so that those are very far
advanced pawns but it's only good if
it's good here maxine goes nice to g4
and now the question is how do you
defend the e5 pawn well this is what you
had in mind
he plays east six here and well it just
seems like in every game between you and
the maxime over I use a deep on and upon
are just marching up the board and okay
maxime captures it it does seem to be a
free pawn and now comes Bishop to c4 now
hoping it that if captures captures and
you can also pick up this point as
Bishop will capture with check but
Maxine finds a very nice decision so he
plays Bishop to a4 now forcing you to
deal with the rook on d1 we look back to
c1 and now even b5 pushing the bishop
further back Bishop to e2 and only now
he captures on d5 and now Maxime is
preparing e5 d 4 and with this kind of
pawn mass in the center he would just be
winning so the question is can you grab
the e7 point if he can it's great if he
can't then after this pawn moves it's
just gonna be an overwhelming position
to deal with Maxime still has the bishop
pair the the semi open file for his a 8
rook and well it's hard to say can you
capture the point but you need the wind
so he doesn't want to allow a 5 he grabs
it not with that but with the Bishop
Bishop captures on e7 we have worked eh
by maksim attacking the bishop and now
Bishop to g5 the problem for white is
that his King is still on on a1 and you
can't really castle as the bishop would
be hanging here so with B for clearing
the be 5 square 4 for his light square
bishop and now comes King to f1 you have
to unpin if you don't want to allow this
but now comes something Maxime had
planned and the white Bishop captures on
e7 essentially doesn't work so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning move for Maxime in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on being such an
excellent exchange sacrificer and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook captures Ani too so it doesn't
matter if the King unpinned the ideas it
still applies if you don't want to be
down a piece you have to capture the
rook so King captures Ani to and only
now Bishop to b5 check so what do you do
here King to e1 and here maxime just
played Bishop the c3 check and it was in
this position unmoved 24 that you only
resigned the game and it is Maxie
marshal Grover who claims third place at
the fitti World Cup 2019 and with this
he's also he will also be taken into
consideration consideration as the
wild-card for the affiliate 2020
candidates tournament if he doesn't
qualify through the feeder Grand Prix
but you know it's always good to have
more chances as two years ago he he
really got he didn't manage to qualify
for the can determine and he almost
qualified by reading almost qualified
through the World Cup almost qualified
through the Grand Prix it was just a
really bad luck for him
so very exciting to see that he's doing
well now and of course a white resigned
here as there is nothing more to do
white is in check you cannot go anywhere
on the on the white squares you could
block there should be two that doesn't
work because of rook to e8 check you're
gonna go king d1 and now Bishop a4 check
you don't have a move you have to give
up the rook but then black and choose
does he want this rule does you want
this rook check King c1 you're just
gonna grab this one for free this one
falls next complete Massacre here on the
other hand if you don't block if you
play something like King d1 it's even
worse Knight captures f2 check King c2
Bishop d3 with check King b3 and now of
course rook to a3 is checkmate very nice
stuff and lastly but not leastly
if you want to give up give the exchange
back with rook captures on c3 just be
captures on c3 and okay you've given
back the exchange but black will have an
easy when the Rope is coming down here
you once you consolidate you're gonna
start pushing your C pawn you have to
connected passed pawns in the center of
the board while white still has problems
getting his rook into the game
completely winning for black so you of
course knows this and
after Bishop to c3 check he resigns at
the game so very interesting stuff and a
lot of you have been asking how does the
whole qualification for the candidates
work well it's a very complicated
process but basically it's a giri who
qualifies through rating and there's a
lot of going on on that you know a whole
whole story as a Maxime I think he would
have to win 27 rating points on up until
November so he could qualify by rating
even though he he's higher rated and
Giri he he's a average over the past
twelve months is lower than Geary's but
then again there's this thing that where
Gary had to play in the isle of man
chess tournament and then he said that
he will not play there but there's no
good there's no good punishment for for
not playing because Gary will now not
play any class grim so he doesn't lose
ratings and it says after you register
for the tournament you cannot you know
abandon your registration and say I'm
just not going to play the tournament
you can only do it
they say if you've qualified for the
candidates tournament through the World
Cup where that's not the case with Gary
so it's interesting to see what will
happen
will he be fined in any way will there
be a punishment or will they just you
know look the other way you know always
exciting stuff in the chess world but
yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank FL team and all
been in Linus Ryan and Charles Schroeder
for a contribution to my channel thank a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon to continue in the coverage of
the Vita World Cup checking up on your
suggestions and so on so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day